okay so let's get started so we spend
quite a bit of time with graph theory in
the first part of this course and today
I want to move beyond that so we're
going to talk about more central topics
in additive combinatorics starting with
the Fourier analytic proof of Roth's
theorem we discussed Ross theorem and we
gave a proof earlier in the course using
similarities graph regularity lemma as
well as the triangle removal Emma today
I want to show you a different approach
to proving Ross theorem that goes
through Fourier analysis so this is a
very important proof and it's one of the
main tools in additive combinatorics let
me remind you what Ross theorem says so
Ross proved in 1953 that if we write our
sub-3 off interval and to be the maximum
size of a 383 subset of 1 to n then
graph showed that our 3 of n is not all
then okay so in other words if you have
a positive density subset of the of the
integers then it must contain a
three-ton or symmetric progression ok so
what I said is equivalent to this
statement here so previously we gave a
proof using regularity
I should the regularity approaches some
relatives only found the 70s so Roth's
original proof was true for your
analysis and we'll see that tomorrow
today we'll see a toy version of this
proof oh it's not really a toy version
it is the same ideas but in a slightly
easier setting that has fewer
technicalities but before showing you
that let me just discuss a bit of
history around Ross theorem we will show
next time the next lecture will show the
bound also by regularity we get some
bound which is little ol event but
because of the use of regularity lemma
it's pretty poor dependence we got
something like n over log star n next
lecture and basically what's original
proof gives you a bound which is n over
log log n so it's a much more reasonable
bound the current best upper bound known
has the form essentially n over log n
raised to 1 plus little 1 roughly and
over log N we do not know or even have
great guesses on what the answer should
be so the best lower bound and this is a
construction that we saw earlier in the
course due to parent is of the form n
over e to the C glued log n it seems it
may be very difficult to improve this
upper bound without some genuine new
ideas on the other hand there are some
evidence that the lower bound might be
closer to the truth
in that there are variants of the
wrought problem for which we know that
the lower bound is basically the truth
[Applause]
what I want to do today is look at a
variant of this problem in what's called
a finite field model and that basically
just means we're going to be looking at
Ross theorem not in the integers but in
some finite field vector space
specifically F 3 to the M so we're going
to define our sub 3 of this F 2 to the N
to be the maximum size of 383 subsets of
this finite field vector space so the
finite field model is really useful
we're going to see this again later in
the course as well many of the ideas
techniques that work for the real
problem so to speak many of those
techniques also work in the finite field
model but they're technically simpler to
execute so this is often you see a
computer that's a sandbox the playing
ground for testing out many of the ideas
and once you have those ideas then you
can see if you can bring them to the
integer setting alright and this is a
very successful program and we'll see in
the one aspect of what happens when we
do this for this specific problem of
Ross theorem in F 3 to the N there are
some nice interpretations of what this
poem means so so here's a pretty easy
fact that 4 so in F 3 to the N for 3
elements X Y Z the following
interpretations of what it means to be a
3 AP are equivalent so X Y Z form a 3 AP
ok so 3 AP means the Y is X plus DZ x
plus 2d equivalently they satisfy this
equation X minus 2 y plus Z equals to 0
ok in F 3 minus 2 is plus
one so the same as this even
nice-looking equation X plus y plus Z
equals to zero it also turns out to be
the same as saying that XYZ a lie on a
line so they what they are a line so the
line has three points in F 3 and if you
look at the coordinate that for every
eye the eyes coordinate XYZ are all
distinct or all equal that's easy to
check all these things are equivalent to
each other and the last one that's a
nice interpretation in terms of a game
that many of you know a set so in the
game set you have a bunch of cards there
are some number of properties and
properties I color the number of symbols
shape and you want to form a set being 3
cards such that every property they're
all same or all different so that's
exactly this model over here all right
so what can we say about this problem
what's the size of the maximum subset of
F 3 to the N without free ap if you look
at the proof that we did earlier in this
course the one using triangle removal
Emma you see the proof works verbatim
right previously we worked over Z more
then now you work over a different group
same proof so triangle removal Emma it
tells you that this R 3 is always little
of the size of the space but we would
like to do better so this gives you
something like block star it's not very
good dependence so we would like to do
better so what we will show today ok so
this theorem is are too bitter to eschew
them
so in this case the water history is
somewhat reversed so we'll see fine I
feel toy model but if historically
actually came afterwards but you'll see
that the four year and then the D proof
that was see today it's basically the
same proof in the two settings so fr3 we
will proof abound or just like that
okay so much better than them when you
get from the regularity method in terms
of okay so let me talk a bit more about
the history of this pump in terms of
what we know in terms of upper bounds
and lower bounds so let me say so what's
the best that you might hope for was the
best lower bound is a dell and it's some
construction some very specific
construction which gives you a pound
that's something like to point to one to
the end and the upper bound is three to
the N on the three- little one to the n
so for a long time it was open whether
the answer should be basically on
roughly like three to the N or some
constant less than three to the N an
improvement on the upper bound were very
slow and or some very difficult work
Stan Nagy that down below just a little
bit and then a couple years ago a few
years ago there was this incredible
breakthrough where in this paper that
was just a couple pages long they
managed to significantly improve the
upper bound to
basically 2.76 to the end
so this was an incredible breakthrough
that happened just a few years ago and
we'll talk about this proof in a couple
of lectures it turns out this proof
which uses what's now called the
polynomial method so not for you
analytic but a different method
unfortunately does not seem to
generalize to the original ross theorem
in fact you shouldn't expect it to
generalize in a straightforward way
because up there you know that you do
not have a power saving whereas here you
have a power saving so the exponent goes
down okay so this is roughly the history
of this theorem any questions sir yeah
so I'll okay this is known as a crew
left hawk say more about it in a couple
lectures but this for F 3 is due to LM
very king high strike but I'll tell you
more about it in a couple lectures what
I want to focus on today is the Fourier
analytic nature of the proof that gives
you this up there 3 to the N over N and
it may seem like a completely different
topic compared to what we've been doing
so far in the course which is more about
graph theory but I want you to think
about what are the relationships between
wall wall say today and what we've seen
so far and there are lots of connections
right so even though the proof nice
superficially look quite different many
of these ideas about quasi randomness
versus structure will come up and I want
to present the proof in a way that
highlights the similarities between what
we did previously and this four-year
analytic truth so let's talk about the
strategy in the proof of the SEM
radiographed regular
our dilemma we had the strategy that we
call the energy increment strategy so
you start you want to find a good
partition you start doing partitioning
and you keep track of this thing called
the energy must go up and every step
cannot go up forever so has a bounded
number of steps the strategy for Ross
theorem is also an important strategy
it's a variant of energy increment but
now density increment so we start with a
set a subset of f2 to the M and we would
like to understand something about its
structure versus pseudo randomness in a
way that is similar to when we discussed
the similar issue for for graphs in
particular there will be this dichotomy
that if a is in some sense pseudo random
okay so earlier we saw what it means for
a graph to be pseudo random so now what
is the mean for a subset of F 3 to the N
to be pseudo random so we'll address
that today if a is pseudo random so the
short answer is that it is for a uniform
in other words all Fourier coefficients
small that's what pseudo random will
refer to so then there is a counting
lemma and the counting lemma what in
particular imply that a has lots of 3
ApS ok so then you find your three AP if
this is not the case then ok so what's
the opposite of for a uniform is that a
now has some large Fourier coefficient
and what we'll do is to use this for you
a coefficient to extract some Co
dimension one affine subspace it's also
called a hyperplane where the density of
a goes up significantly if you restrict
to that hyperplane and you can repeat
this process now restrict to this
hyperplane and ask yourself the same
question this a will restrict it to this
hyperplane pseudo random in which case
we find a piece or is a restricted this
hyperplane does have a large Fourier
coefficient in which case we restrict
further and each time you iterate you're
paying a density increment and the
density increment cannot go on forever
because your total density is at most
one so the number of steps must be
bounded so that's the strategy so you
should remind you somewhat of the energy
increment strategy from similarities
regularity lemma although there are some
fundamental differences we're not doing
partitioning any questions of other
strategy ok I want to tell you about
Fourier analysis
so probably all of you have seen some
version of Fourier analysis maybe in
your calculus class with for you serious
and whatnot and so you play with
formulas and solve some differential
equations so I want to give you you know
more than just a bunch of ways about
handling Fourier coefficients a way to
think about Fourier analysis so think of
this as a crash course about Fourier
analysis from the perspective of
combinatorics and Fourier analysis I
think it's much easier if you work in a
finite group in the finite abelian group
which is what we're doing here many of
the technicalities go away so we'll be
looking specifically at Fourier analysis
in F 3 to the M although three can be
any prime so it's really the same so the
main actors in Fourier analysis are the
four-year characters the Fourier
characters are denoted gamma sub R and
there are characters on the group
meaning that there are maps which
paternal happen to be homomorphisms for
the multiplicative group under as well
see under multiplication and they're
indexed by r which also elements of F 3
to the N so I'm going to be fairly
concrete here there are ways to do this
more abstractly but I'll be fairly
concrete so it's defined by gamma sub R
evaluated on x equals to Omega raise to
r dot product X where here Omega is a
third root of unity and the dot is a dot
product
okay so that's the definition of the
Fourier transform you know that's the
best definition the for your characters
and once you have the Fourier characters
you can have this Fourier transform just
define as follows if you start with a
function let's say a complex valued
function on your space then I define the
Fourier transform to be another function
like that defined by following formula
okay so that's the formula for the
Fourier transform it has basically the
inner product between F and the
four-year character and so let me make
the comment here I think this is
actually a pretty important comment
about the normalization now when you
first learn Fourier transforms usually
in the reals there are all these
questions about what number to put in
the exponent is a 2 pi is a root 2 pi is
some other thing and you know somehow
one answer is better than the others and
the same thing is true here in groups so
we'll stick with the following
convention and I won't all of you to
stick with this convention otherwise
we'll confuse ourselves to no end
is that for a finite group
[Applause]
let me start a new board so the
convention is that in a finite group the
Fourier transform is defined and more
generally anything you do in the
physical space we always use the
averaging measure don't some always
average in the physical space and in the
frequency space always use some use the
counting measure keep this in mind any
of these questions about normalization
if you stick with this convention things
will become much easier so there won't
be any of these questions about when you
take the inverse Fourier transform do I
put an extra factor in in front or not
if you stick with this correct
convention so with that convention in
mind what the Fourier transform really
is in your product between F and a for
your character okay there are some
important properties of the Fourier
transform so let me go through a few of
the key properties that we'll need the
first one is pretty easy one is the
meaning of the 0th fourier coefficient
you plug it in and you see that it is
just the average of F ok so 0 the
coefficient is the average of F the
second fact goes on there one of two
names and they're often used
interchangeably clench RL or parsable
and it says that if you look at the
inner product in the physical space then
this in your product is preserved if you
take the Fourier transform but now of
course you're in the frequency space so
you should sum instead of doing the
inner product okay so this identity can
be proved in a fairly straightforward
way by plugging in what the definition
is for the Fourier transform now this is
a straightforward computation I'm not
going to do on the board where that
highly encouraged to actually do at home
not just do it once to make sure you
understand how it goes but there's also
a more conceptual way to understand this
identity and that's because you can I
know this is also important to you to
understand what the Fourier transform is
it's not just some magical formula
somebody wrote down like this is a very
natural operation it's because the
characters the set of characters is an
orthonormal basis so then for your
characters form an orthonormal basis as
a result what the Fourier transform is
is a unitary change of basis
you can check it's very straightforward
to check that before your character's
indeed formal orthonormal basis because
well you can evaluate the inner product
between two for your characters so
remember in the physical space we're
always doing averaging and so now so
just write down first what I mean by the
inner product so that's the inner
product and by the definition of the
Fourier character you have that so think
about what this expectation is unless R
equals to s in which case this
expectation is 1 ok unless that is the
case you always have some coordinate of
X in the exponent so as you add which
over all possibilities they average out
to 0 ok so this calculation shows you
that the for your characters from a
orthonormal basis and the basic fact you
know from linear algebra is that if we
do a change of basis if you do an
unitary change of basis then your
product is preserved but it's like a
rotation it's the same so you're not
changing the inner product so inner
product is preserved under this change
of basis and that's that's why plants
are always too
another important thing is what's known
as the Fourier inversion formula the
Fourier transform tells you how to go
from a function to be Fourier transform
or now if you are given the Fourier
transform how do you go back there's a
formula which tells you that you can go
back by the following okay so that's the
Fourier inversion formula it allows you
to to do this inversion and again it's
one of these formulas where I encourage
you to try it out yourself by plugging
in the formula and expanding and it's
pretty easy to check it's much easier in
the finite field setting by the way so
if you use the usual Fourier transform
on the real line there are some
technicalities even to prove the for
your inversion but in finite groups it's
almost trivial you expand and then you
will see it's very easy to prove but you
can also see this Fourier inversion
formula more conceptually because you're
in a unitary change-of-basis so to go
back I'll think about what it means
linear algebra to revert a unitary
transformation you simply multiply the
coefficients with the coordinates
talking all orthonormal change of basis
finally Fourier transform behaves well
under convolution so by convolution we
define the convolution of two functions
F and G using following formula
okay and so then the claim is that the
Fourier transform behaves very well
under convolution it it's basically
multiplicative okay so what this means
is if I put in so it's point wise true
everywhere again very easy proof because
I just evaluate the left hand side see
what plug in the formula for the Fourier
transform and I find that and now I plug
in the formula for convolution and so
now you can do a change of variables and
it's not hard to see you eventually end
up at the right-hand side okay so these
are some of the properties so there are
important properties of the Fourier
transform so this is something that
whenever you learn about Fourier
transform you always always see these
few properties and so we'll use them but
we'll also need another property that is
specific to the analysis of three time
arithmetic progressions so what does
Fourier transform have to do with three
APs
so we want to use it to prove roster so
we better have some tool that allows us
to analyze the number of three APs and
here's the key identity relating Fourier
with three a piece and it's that if you
have three functions and the following
quantity which relates the number of
three a piece okay so this function
basically counts the number three a
piece if you are F G and H are indicator
functions of a set I want to express
this formula in terms of the Fourier
transforms of these functions the
formula turns out to be fairly simple
that is simply okay so it's a single sum
over the arse of F hat of our G hat of
minus 2r each kind of our you might
wonder why I put a minus two here this
minus two is our and it looks certainly
much nicer with just our in there and
that is to this formula as written is
true for over any group and our proof
will show it so it's not really about f3
at all but any group that me okay so let
me prove this for you in in a couple of
different ways so the first proof is
basically a straight forward you know no
thinking involved proof as in we apply
this formula for using either Fourier
inversion or for you or the inverse for
you
transform and plug it in and expand and
check so it's worth doing at least this
one so let's let's do this together at
least once but this is something that is
a fairly straightforward computation the
left-hand side can be expanded using for
your inversion so R 1 F 1/2 R 1 Omega to
the minus R 1 dot X sum over R 2 G hat R
2 Omega to the minus R 2 dot X plus y
and then finally some of our 3 H hat of
our 3 Omega to the minus R 3 dot X plus
2y ok so I'm using Fourier inversion
replace F G and H by their by their
Fourier transforms sorry there should be
- ok so now we exchange sums and
expectations to us switch in the water
summation R 1 R 2 R 3 and F hat of R 1 G
hat of R 2 H half of R 3 and you have
this expectation over x + y + Omega of X
dot R 1 plus R 2 sorry talk I can even
write the X and y separately why Omega
why dot are two plus two okay so just
rearranging and now you see that as you
take expectation over X this expectation
is equal to 1 if r1 plus r2 plus r3 is
equal to 0 and 0 otherwise
and likewise the third expectation is
either 1 or 0 depending on the sums of
our to and r3 so the only terms that
remain after you take out these zeros
are cases where both these two equations
are satisfied and then you see that the
only remaining terms are basically the
ones given in the sum on the right hand
side okay so that's the proof pretty
straightforward you plug in for a
version I want to show you a different
proof that hopefully will be more
familiar and more conceptual that
doesn't involve carrying through this
calculation even though this is not a
little hard calculation but first let me
rewrite the formula up there so in F 3
will be convenient and so formula it's
actually slightly easier to interpreting
F 3 and F 3 the identity says that if
you look at the quantity
I mean so let me give you a second proof
that works just in f3 but you can modify
it working other groups but you have to
it's particularly nice the left-hand
side you see the reference side I can
rewrite it as the following form where I
sum over when I take expectation over
all triples XYZ that's sum to 0 because
the 3 AP is the same as three elements
free points in the vector space summing
to zero but now you see that this
quantity is the same as a convolution
evaluated at zero so if you extend the
definition of convolution to more than
one form or than two functions but now
we apply for a inversion and we find
that ok so by Fourier inversion you have
that but now by the identity that
relates the Fourier transform and
inversion you have that and that's
that's the proof because minus two are
the same as are so it's it's shorter is
we're using some properties here about
convolution and yes about the
convolution
that formula up there is of course
related to counting three atps because
if F G and H are all indicators of some
set then the left-hand side is the same
as basically the number of triples of
elements in ape whose sum is equal to
zero and the right-hand side is the sum
of the third power of the Fourier
coefficients and this formula should
look somewhat familiar because we also
use this kind of formulas back when we
discussed spectral graph theory and
remember the third moment of eigenvalues
is the trace of the third power which
counts closed walks in a Kayla graph so
this is actually the same formula so so
in the case if a is symmetric let's say
then this is the same as the formula
that counts closed walks of length 3
in a KD graph at the point of this
common is just to tell you that you know
Fourier transform is somehow it's not
this brand new concept that we've never
seen before it is intimately tied to
many of the things we have seen earlier
in this course but in disguise so it is
related to the spectral graph theory
that we discussed at length earlier in
this course okay now that we have the
Fourier transform I want to develop some
machinery to prove RAAS theorem
following the strategy up there ok so
let's take a quick break and then when
we come back we'll prove RAAS theorem
any questions so far
ok so question is where do we use that
word you in F 3 to the N this formula
here holding every finite abelian group
if you use the correct definition of
Fourier transform with the averaging
normalization so in the other formula
where you replace -2 by one that
requires F 3 but you can I mean you can
follow the proof and come up with a
similar formula for every equation yeah
so there's a general principle here
which I'll discuss more length in a bit
that for patterns that are covered by a
single equation in this case 3 a piece X
minus 2y plus Z equal to 0 patterns that
can be governed by a single equation can
be controlled by a Fourier transform
so let's begin our proof a four-year
analytic proof of roster I mean that's
free to the okay so you're asking about
the final step where we we're talking
about so I mentioned that there's this
connection between counting walks and
graphs and spectral graph theory so you
can check that if you have a sub set a
of an abelian group then the Fourier
transforms of a are exactly the
eigenvalues of the katy graph okay
question where is the Fourier analysis
better than the spectral posted so let's
see the proof first so there's no graphs
anymore so we're gonna work inside f2 to
the M but just like the proof of
regularity and County we're gonna have a
counting number
okay so all of these are analytic and at
this point you know they should be very
familiar to you they may have they may
come in different form they may be not
dressed in different clothing but it's
still a counting them so let's see the
county lemma in this case says that if
you are in setting of a as 2 to the M
and I'm going to throughout right the
density of a as alpha
then let me write okay let me define
this lambda 3/8 to be the function which
basically counts 3 a piece in a but with
the averaging normalization so this is
we saw this earlier so the counting
lemma says that this normalized number 3
piecing a so including trivial three
keys sorry this is a nice analytic
expression differs from what you might
guess based on density alone this
difference should be small if all the
nonzero four-year coefficients of a are
small so in this strategy I said that if
to the counting lemma tells you if a is
for a uniform then is a pseudo random
and this is where it comes in if a has
all small Fourier coefficients then you
have a counting lemma which tells you
that the counter base should not be so
different from the guess based on
density so the proof is very short it's
based on the identity that we saw
earlier the three count of a by the
identity earlier is simply the third
power of the Fourier transforms all of
these calculations should be reminiscent
because we've done these kind of
calculations in some form or another
earlier in this course so we're going to
separate out the main term
and subsequent terms so the main term is
the one corresponding to R equals to
zero so that's the density and all the
other terms I'm going to lump together
into some so we now know that the
difference we're trying to bound is
upper bounded by the third moment of the
absolute values of the Fourier transform
and I want upper bound this quantity
here assuming that all of these Fourier
coefficients are small we've also done
this kind of calculations before okay so
where have we seen this before we saw
this calculation earlier in the class
for the three replaced by a four okay so
in counting four cycles in approval
equivalents or quasi randomness we said
that if all the eigenvalues after the
top one are small then you can count
four cycles it's the same proof and
remember in that proof there was there
was a important trick where you do not
uniformly bound each term by the max
because then you lose you lose by an
extra factor of n that you don't want so
you only take out one factor so you take
out one factor and you keep the rest in
there in fact I can be more generous and
even throw the R equal to zero turn back
in and now buy plenty RL so buy plenty
all possible this here is equal to the
expectation of
a the indicator function of a square so
you take this go back to physical space
and that's simply the density so then
that proves the theorem okay so the
moral of the counting lemma is the same
as the one that we've seen before we
discuss graphs if you're in pseudo
random then you have good counting
and here pseudo random means having
small fourier coefficients uniformly
small for your coefficients so now let's
begin the proof of roster the Ross
theorem proof will have three steps
first step we will observe that between
a 3 a p3 set then there exists a large
48 coefficient throughout I'm going to
use uppercase n to denote the size of
the ambient group specifically we will
prove the following and also throughout
a subset of F 3 to the N and with
density alpha so keep this convention
throughout this proof we will show that
if a is 383 and and this at least 2 to
the alpha to the minus 2 so n is at
least somewhat large then there exists a
nonzero R such that the our Fourier
coefficient is at least alpha squared
over 2 if your 3 AP free then provided
that you're working in a large enough
ambient space you always have some large
for a coefficient so the proof it's
essentially it's this claim is
essentially a corollary of counting them
up by the counting lemma and using the
fact that in a three AP through set what
is the quantity lambda three of a up
there you only have the trivial three AP
is present so so this quantity lambda
must then be size of a divided by N
squared or alpha over N which are
precisely counting a trivial piece okay
so by the counting amount then we have
that the upper bound on the right hand
side which we now write alpha max over
non zero ours yes
at least alpha cubed minus lambda three
term which should be alpha over N so
provided that n is large enough big n is
large enough then the trivial sweep he
should not contribute very much so I can
lower bound the right hand side by I say
alpha 3 alpha cubed over two so that you
deduce the conclusion okay I want you to
think about how this proof is related to
similarities graph regularity lemma the
analogy won't break down at some point
but no we've seen this step before as
well from lack of three a piece you
extract some useful information and from
this floor extract some structure and
the structure here and this is where the
proof now diverges from that of
regularity having a large Fourier
coefficient
will now imply a density increment
specifically if you have okay so keeping
the same convention this before if the
free a coefficient of a R is at least
Delta for some nonzero R then a has
density at least alpha plus Delta over 2
when restricted to a hyperplane
restricted to so if you have a large
Fourier coefficient then I can pass down
to a smaller part of the space where the
density of a goes up significantly to
see why this is true let's go back to
the definition of the Fourier
coefficient the Fourier transform so
recall that the Fourier transform is
given by the following formula where I'm
looking at this expectation over points
in f2 to the N together with an
indicator of a multiplied by this for
your character and you see that this
function here
it is constant cosets of the hyperplane
defined by the orthogonal complement of
our so the value of this dot product is
is constant on the three hyper planes so
I can rewrite this expectation simply as
one-third of alpha naught plus l4 one
Omega plus alpha 2 Omega squared where
alpha naught alpha 1 alpha 2 are the
densities of a on the three cassettes of
our trip so group this expectation into
these three hyper planes so now you see
that if this guy is large then you
should expect that alpha naught alpha 1
and alpha 2 are not all too close to
each other suddenly if they were equal
to each other you should get zero but
you should not expect them to be too
close to each other in particular we
would want to say that one of them goes
up it's much bigger than alpha so one of
these there must be much bigger than
alpha
that's an elementary inequality with
something I'm sure I give you five
minutes you can figure out but let me
show you a small trick to show this and
the reason for this trick is because the
next lecture when we look at Ross
theorem over the integers we'll need
this extra trick
and the trick here is this we now know
that because of the hypothesis 3 Delta
is lower bound to the absolute value of
alpha naught plus alpha 1 Omega plus
alpha 2 Omega squared and ok so note
here that the average of the three
alphas is equal to the original alpha by
definitions of density so this in your
some I can read right back ok so the sum
of the three groups of unity add up to
zero and now I apply triangle inequality
to extract the terms ok so now you
should already deduce that one of the
alpha ice has to be significantly larger
than alpha and has to be significantly
different but the only three terms one
of them has to be significantly larger
but let me do this one extra trick which
we'll need next time which is that I let
me add an extra term like that which
sums out to zero but now you see that
each summand is always non-negative
right so one of the so there exists some
J such that Delta lower bounds that Jade
summoned and if you look at what that
means then
lower bounds the chief summoned some
particular this sum here should be no
negative so we obtain a density
increment on this hyperplane and finally
I want to iterate this density increment
so I want to iterate this density
increment so summary so far is that we
have so if stat3 with tens to the alpha
and at least 2 to the power 5 to the
minus 2 then a density at least alpha
plus of a squared over 4 on some
hyperplane so you combine step 1 and
step 2 we obtain this conclusion well I
can now repeat this operation so I can
repeat by restricting a to this
hyperplane a is originally 383 I
restrict it to a hyperplane it's still
383 so I can keep going I can keep going
provided on MySpace
large enough because I still need this
lower bound on yeah don't forget this
one here so I can keep going as long as
and is so I'm using n sub J to denote
what happens after the Jade step I can
keep going as long as this is still
satisfying but of course you cannot keep
on going forever because the density is
bounded right so density cannot exceed
one so these two walk if you abound on
the total dimension so let's work this
out so let alpha I denote the density
after step I in this iteration and we
see from over here that you start with
density alpha and each step you go up by
an increment which is basically what you
go up by some increment and you want to
know if you start with alpha how many
steps and most can you take before you
blow out one okay so can you give me
some pound so what's the maximum and
most how many steps
so we know that the density cannot
exceed one use so see that you have at
most four over alpha squared steps
because density is at most one and if
you plug this in you get something which
is not quite what I stated so it turns
out that if you plug this in you find
that alpha is you find that the size of
a is at most three to the N over square
root n okay so let me do a little bit
better right so then simply seeing that
this term here is at least alpha squared
over four and the point is that when you
increment you increment faster and
faster right so I can use that to give a
better bound on a number of steps and
here's here's the way to see it so
starting at alpha and I now ask how many
steps do you need to take before it
doubles it goes up by alpha squared over
four so it doubles after at most four
over alpha steps and at which point this
alpha new alpha becomes at least the
original twice the original alpha but
now you keep going how many times does
it take to double again to alpha because
the Alpha became twice as much
so doubles again after almost two over
alpha steps and then you keep going the
next iteration is one over alpha so in
total right so you see that we must stop
after and most eight over alpha steps
it's the number of times it doubles
actually decreases by at least half each
all right so now we know that we see
that the so you keep on going so you
must stop after most eight over alpha
steps what is the final density when you
have to stop okay so whenever you force
to stop you are forced to stop if you
run out of space okay so you're forced
to stop we run out of space so if the
process terminates after M steps so we
are at density alpha M so then the final
final space sub space size less than two
to the alpha M to the raise to minus two
which is okay so now I use this bound
alpha
so the initial n is upper bounded by
what so how many steps did you take you
took a most 8 over alpha steps each of
those steps you pass down to Co
dimension one you lose the dimension for
each step and the final subspace has at
least this has the most that many that
much space so the final dimension is
this basically block one over alpha so
put them together we see that the size
of the space fortunately is at most one
over alpha think there should be a
lowercase n so the dimension then that's
the conclusion the density alpha is Big
O of 1 over ok that proves the main
theorem for today so brass theorem over
F 3 to the N ok so we went through this
free analytic proof next lecture we will
see the same proof again but done in the
integers for interval and there there
are some difficulties that we don't see
over here because in the finite field
space in the finite field model there's
this very nice idea of looking at
subspaces so looking at hyper planes
each fourier coefficient get you down to
one dimension less but when you're
working in the integers there are no
subspaces you can use ok so we'll be
looking at ways to get around the lack
of sub
faces and this is why I said in the
beginning that the finite field model is
often a very good playground for for
additive combinatorics type techniques
especially for a analytic techniques
because in the additive in all of these
techniques they just come out to be much
cleaner if you're working in a finite
field setting nice subspaces you have
Fourier transform in a very clean way
the Fourier transform always takes in
this case one of three values
everything's very clean everything's
very simple and you get a C the idea
here you can see this density increment
argument but once you understand those
ideas and you're willing to do more in
more work then oftentimes you can bring
those ideas to other settings to other
abelian groups to the integers for
instance but with more work in the
there's some extra ingredients that you
need to use I mentioned that there was a
pound
okay so initially so okay so next time
we'll see that next time we'll see what
happens over the integers any questions
yes okay great so questions why the
process must stop after at most 8 over
alpha steps so you know that the density
doubles after this many steps doubles
again after that many steps so
eventually if it keeps on doubling
cannot keep on doubling forever right so
this process cannot keep on doubling
forever so it must stop so cannot double
more than log base 2 of 1 over alpha
times ok and that point you you have to
stop so how many steps have you taken
well you sum this geometric series so
this sound and the next thing is now you
sum this geometric series and that
geometric series sums to 8 over alpha ok
so let's finish it so next time we'll
see
raus proof of Roth's theorem